hey everyone this is kevin from the
chest website comm today we're gonna be
going over how to solve different
puzzles if you play chess for any amount
of time you've probably come across many
puzzles they are very enjoyable to do
but if you haven't seen a video like
this or had someone sit down and explain
how to do a video more than likely you
have come across many different puzzles
that you just can't solve and you really
have no idea how to approach that so
today in this video I want to go over
two puzzles that are really going to
teach you some basic ideas on how you
should approach a puzzle and different
things that you should be looking for
now both of these puzzles are posted the
links in the description below on
youtube so if you want to go to the
website the chess website calm and
practice these puzzles before you
actually watch the video feel free to do
that the first example that we're gonna
be talking about is posted on the chess
page on Facebook if you're not already a
fan of the chess page on Facebook I'll
have a link below in the YouTube
description definitely make sure that
you're a fan of this there's a ton a ton
of fantastic information posted on that
Facebook page so we'll go ahead and get
into it the first example if we look at
it right here it is white smooth and it
is white to mate in three now the first
thing we want to do as far as any chess
puzzle is look at it and see if our
Punnett skin can move especially again
if this is a mate in a certain number of
moves in this case our opponent's King
cannot move now why can this King not
move he can't come to h7 because our
night here on g5 is blocking and it
can't come to h5 because our King here
is on h4 because of that this is very
important to know more than likely the
night here on g5 and the King here on h4
are not going to move again they are
keeping the King at bay if the King
cannot move more than likely you're
going to be using your other pieces to
try to check your opponent now this may
seem elementary as well but if the King
cannot move for your opponent and you
put him in check that is going to be
checkmate so with that said it
we need to figure out a way to use one
of our other pieces to check the
opponent's king so the first thing I
want to look at is this night here on f3
now the first thing we want to do as far
as this knight on f3 is we need to
figure out where that Knight could go to
check our opponents King now we're not
thinking about if that piece is
threatened or that square is threatened
or who can stop it we're gonna worry
about that later first we need to figure
out where this night could end up that
could check this opponents King again
this King cannot move so as long as we
check that King it's going to be
checkmate so if we look at it I'm gonna
go and highlight the squares here if we
can get our knight here to g4 again
that's checkmate if we can get our
knight here to f7 checkmate and again
Knight here to GFS checkmate now I know
again I'm not I'm not even looking at
these squares that can be attacked by
black here I'm just looking at the
squares that we can move our Knight to
they could checkmate the King here on h6
now if we do look at it we can see this
pawn are the excuse me the square on f7
and this square on g4 can be reached in
two moves so we can move our Knight to
e5 and then we can move it to f7 or g4
it's gonna be actually very very
difficult to get our Knights to g8 as
you can see it's gonna take many many
more moves to come to g8 since we only
have three moves in this entire puzzle
more than likely I'm gonna go ahead and
rule out this g8 square so right away we
know if the knight is going to end up
making the checkmate it's going to be on
g4 or f7 now right away we don't know if
the Knights gonna be the one giving that
final blow it could be the Queen we now
need to go over the possibilities for
the Queen now if we look at the Queen
here we can see really the only move
that we could possibly get to in any
amount of time is going to be this h8
square so we know that we do have a
possibility obviously we could get
therefore you know we moved you know to
e8 and then over to h8 or if we moved up
to b8 then we could come over to h8
either of these is going to deliver a
checkmate again we're not looking at the
black pieces right
we're gonna worry about that later but
right now we pretty much know that the
queen is either gonna be on h8 and
deliver the fatal blow or we're gonna
end up having our night here on g4 or
it's gonna be here on f7 so now that we
know all of our threats we can now start
to work on the puzzle now as we talked
about before we'd really like to bring
our Knight to e5 again that's kind of
the hub where it can come to f7
checkmate or g4 checkmate depending on
where our pun it goes so first we know
we really need to move this Queen first
again we don't want to move our knight
anywhere farther away from this e5
square and we also do not want to move
either our night here on g5 or our King
here on h4 at least right away again the
King cannot move here later on down the
road if something you know changes we
may have to move them but for now we do
not want to move this knight on d5 or
are keen hearing aids for unless we have
to unless there's going to be a force to
mate so if we kind of look at our
different options for our Queen here as
we've talked about before really are our
best threats that we have for our queen
is if he can come to h8 again we do have
this rook here on a8 but if we move our
Queen anywhere else he's really not
going going to help us obviously our
opponent is gonna try everything he can
to do to stop our knight coming to e5
and if we only have one threat if our
Knight is coming to e5 and he can stop
that well it's gonna be really hard to
find checkmate in three so we really
only have two options again we need to
bring have the possibility that our
Queen comes to h8 so we have Queen to e8
and we also have Queen to b8 again our
next move is more than likely going to
be followed up with Knight to e5 all
things considering depending on what
black does however choose to do so from
here black has two different options
obviously he can take here on b8 and
then white can now come to e5 and
there's no stopping white now there's
nothing to black and do that can stop
both this Knight to f7
or this Knight to g4 now black does not
obviously have to take here if he
doesn't take it if he says you know what
this night is gonna come here to e5
I really have to stop that then he could
bring his rook down to a five again he
is now stopping this Knight here coming
to e5 but again as we talked about
before we have to know all of our
threats that we have we also have this
threat of Queen to h8 and this is also
checkmate
so again black really doesn't have a lot
of good options these are pretty much
the forced options you can either take
on b8 and we're gonna checkmate with our
Knight here or he can come down to a 5
and then we're pretty much going to win
with our queen now I do want to cover
one last option for those who really
like to get in depth in the puzzles and
they always use you know try to comment
and say hey you know what about this
this really weird variation that I found
that no one would actually do but you
know it doesn't work on that so again as
we've talked about more than likely you
will see the the black AI for the
computer when you solve this puzzle move
but if a human would actually bring his
Bishop down to f5 again we couldn't now
bring our Knight to e5 because the
bishop could come to e6
he's now defending both this square here
on f7 and he's also defending these
square on g4 again both of the scores
that we're really trying to hit on we
still can't bring our queen to h8
because again the rook here is on a a so
instead of coming to be 5 first we are
first going to come to f7 with our
Knight and then the only move that he
has is to come to h7 and now we can
finish up with our nights here on g5
again he cannot move back here because
of our Knights and again he can't move
up because of our Queen here on b8 so as
we talked about before we didn't want
have to move this night if we have to
but as you can see we we it we still
ended up with a night here on g5 so
unless something crazy happens again you
want to really want to focus on the
pieces that you have keeping your Yorkie
your opponent's king at bay and then you
want to move your other pieces and see
how you can arrange those to checkmate
your opponent King typically by just
putting them in check so again in this
case first move is to put them Queen to
b8 and then you have a lot of different
variations if you want to checkmate with
you know your knight or you can always
have the option to bring your Queen over
to h8 so this is a puzzle number one
puzzle number two we'll go ahead and
take a look at the next puzzle is easy
puzzle number seven on the website again
the link will be below in the YouTube
description I definitely encourage you
to take some time now that we've gone
through one puzzle to see if you can
solve this on your own
if you have not already but I'm gonna go
ahead and dive into it again as you can
see this is another example if our
opponents King cannot move again he
cannot come to this seventh rank because
of our rook he cannot come to c6 because
of our pawns here on b5 and d5 he can't
come to c5 or ivar King here and he
can't come to e6 because of our pawn
here on the five so again we first have
to see what pieces and pawns we have
that are keeping this King at bay and as
you can see these are the pieces and
pawns right now that are keeping this
King from moving here now our opponent
does have a LightSquared Bishop there's
no way for him to attack our King so our
King is pretty much safe we don't have
to worry about any random checks from
our opponent there's really no threats
that we can see from our opponents so
really we have two different pieces we
have this bishop here on e one and we
have this night here on h6 and we know
that we need to deliver some sort of
check from one of these pieces or
checkmate
first piece I want to look at is the
bishop here on e one and take a look at
all the possibilities to deliver a check
on our opponent again we first do not
want to really focus too much
on if our piece can be captured we just
want to think about the the the
different possibilities that we have
later on again pieces and pawns are
going to be moved pop possibly so we
want to think about all of the different
variations that we do have now as you
can keep in mind some of these you know
you know square on e7 or square on f8
probably not going to to work as much
it's gonna be really hard to get our
Bishop up here and two moves to deliver
a blow but as you can see you know a
move like Bishop to b4 that would be
checkmate if this bishop are that excuse
me if this pawn here on a4 is not
checkmate or if it's not there again you
know a3 it's much likely that we'd come
to b4 first it would be a lot harder to
bring our Bishop down to a3 but again on
the on the other side as well we do have
all these different options so first
piece we're gonna look at is the bishop
and then secondly we're gonna be looking
at the night here on h6 so just keep all
these gradations in your head again you
know we'd like to come down to g3 if we
could we could come to f4 as a checkmate
again all depending on where blacks
pieces are now we can look at our other
piece our night here on h6 and it's
actually gonna be a little easier and
this time I'm actually gonna only be
looking at the moves that were really
you know possibly gonna be dealing with
again you know he could come over you
know at a different place and deliver
checkmate you know if he was on you know
Knight e4 but again it's he's not gonna
get there so I'm gonna go over the the
possibilities that we may use and that's
gonna be f7 and it's also going to be f5
you know if we came to a5 checkmate if
we came to f7 checkmate again it really
depends on where this Bishop on g6 is if
we move right away that's gonna be
pretty terrible because it doesn't
matter if we come to f5 he takes or if
we come to Jesus our excuse me f7
he's going to take right away so as we
can see the two squares that we want to
go with our Knight we really don't want
to do that right away because we're
going to lose our checkmate into because
of the bishop
on g6 so I have these two pieces we know
our Knights really not the best move so
we need to find the best square for our
Bishop because our Bishop is going to be
our first move and this is a very
important point especially in this
puzzle we have to think about where our
opponent can move now our opponent has
three different moves that he can make
he can bring he can move his pawn to a4
that is a potential move he could bring
his pawn to g4 that is also a potential
move or he can move his bishop now as we
talked about before this Bishop here on
g6 is very important it is defending
both squares of this f7 Square and this
f5 square if this bishop moves anywhere
he is going to lose one of these squares
again our Knights just hanging out here
on h6 it's not threatened it cannot be
taken right away
so if this bishop moves it doesn't
matter if he comes to h5 to h7 to e8 it
doesn't really matter one of these
squares is going to be open so we know
that the bishop cannot move from g6 or
it's gonna be a very very easy checkmate
from us again we know that we have to
move our bishop we have to move it
somewhere at the same token we know that
neither the pawn is going to come to a 4
or this pawn is gonna come to g4 so if
we look at it we know ok we're either
going to have room to bring our Bishop
to b4 or we're gonna have an option to
bring our Bishop to f4 both of these are
going to deliver checkmate so we need to
have a square where it doesn't matter if
he comes to a 4 or if he comes to g4 we
can target both of these squares this be
4 square or this f4 square and that move
is Bishop to d2 if you look at again
it's a fantastic puzzle because again if
this bishop moves doesn't where it
doesn't matter where the bishop moves
it's going to be checkmate if he does
not move his bishop he can either choose
he can either bring it to a 4 and that's
going to be checkmate or he can also
bring his pawn to
g4 and then we bring our Bishop to f4
and that's going to be checkmate so
hopefully you guys were able to solve
this on your own if you weren't
hopefully this allowed you to understand
how to solve puzzles maybe on your own
instead of going puzzled by puzzle I'm
trying to figure out you know each one
individually maybe this will kind of
give you some in-depth knowledge on how
you should approach a puzzle what things
you should be looking for and it should
make your life a whole lot simpler now
going forward we will be going over how
to solve different puzzles you know in
the case that the King can move
typically those are going to be forced
variations where you have to check your
opponent over and over until you have a
forced variation will be going over
those but definitely want to take some
time so many people are curious how to
solve different puzzles than they
typically just want an answer right away
but I thought it'd be better to teach
people how they should actually be
approaching these puzzles to kind of
help them later on down the road
obviously puzzles are a great segment in
your own chess game the more you can
kind of break down a chess game and see
what pieces are used for what it'll
really help your chess I when you get
into a game and you may have this force
checkmate
that you may have missed before but now
knowing kind of how your pieces work
together it will be easier so if you
guys haven't already checked out some
more of the puzzles at the chess website
calm feel free to leave me feedback or
send me any responses about these
puzzles or other puzzles you have
questions about now we'll see you guys
in the neck in the next video thanks for
watching